[Music]
all right people I'm Dave Ruben this is
the rubben report it's December 20th
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subcribe tap
the notification Bell if you have not
postgame show as always Ruben report.
locals.com um and it's Christmas in a
couple days Dave ruin.
store right oh no that way damn this
freaking reverse camera thing we got
hoodies we got hats we got mugs and much
more and your family will love all of
them that is the day of Ruben guarantee
uh we did not do a cold open today
because it is not a great day for
democracy and I couldn't figure out what
to throw in there uh that was going to
set us up in an appropriate way but as
I'm sure all of you watch watching this
no uh there was a ruling in the Colorado
courts yesterday that is going to take
Donald Trump or at least attempt I
should say to take Donald Trump off the
ballot off the primary ballot and this
is a uh let's just say big problem and
not good for democracy so we're going to
uh unpack that a little bit we're going
to get into some of the reaction because
of course some of the usual suspects say
MSNBC people are figuring out a way to
make it sound like it's the right thing
to do to subvert democracy Y and the
will of the people and then of course a
whole bunch of people across the
political Spectrum are actually standing
up for principle and uh and defending
Trump in this case and you guys know I
have been very critical of Donald Trump
over the last 6 months I am not
supporting his uh campaign at the moment
I don't think he would be the best
nominee clearly I think Des santis would
be better but as always I have no
problem defending him or the truth or
what's right uh when it should be
defended ended and this is one of those
cases so we're going to unpack all of
that we also have a Ruben report locals
Community Q&A for you and we'll do that
after I tell you about gravity to fire
guys I want to tell you about something
that's been making my days a whole lot
easier yes gravity to Fire Shoes these
shoes are something else I mean everyone
knows Dave Ruben's a fan of comfortable
Footwear but these shoes take it to a
whole new level more than just shoes
they're basically clouds for your feet
I'm not kidding in a double blind study
by all of you UCL Medical Center and
published in the Journal of the American
podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85% less knee
pain it's the most powerful shock
absorption system put into a shoe
gravity defier has patented Verso shock
technology it's like a mini trampoline
in your shoe whether you're strolling
through the park running errands or even
just lounging at home these shoes have
got your back or I should say your feet
even better they're stylish you get both
comfort and style that look good and
feel great so here's the deal gravity
fire is is offering a limited exclusive
holiday deal just for you just head over
to
gy.com
gdefy Doom use promo code ruben3 and
you'll get an extra 30% off your order
that's an amazing 30% off for being here
today it's a holiday thank you gift from
Gravity to fire why not treat your feet
to some well-deserved Comfort GD fy.
comom promo code ruben3 for 30% off and
now back to me all right so let's just
get right into this hearing out of the
Colorado courts because this thing is
lighting the world a flame right now got
some info from the daily wire the
Colorado Supreme Court removed former
president Donald Trump from the state's
2024 presidential ballot on Tuesday
after ruling that he engaged in an
Insurrection with his actions on January
6th
2021 the 4 to3 ruling will be placed on
hold pending Appeal on January 4th the
court said in its ruling
a majority of the Court holds that
President Trump is disqualified from
holding the off office of president
under section three of the 14th
Amendment of the United States
Constitution the ruling said because he
is disqualified it would be a wrongful
act under the election code for the
Colorado Secretary of State to list him
as a candidate on the presidential
primary ballot the Trump campaign
responded to the ruling by saying that
they would swiftly file an appeal
calling it a completely flawed decision
that was deeply undemocratic we have
full confidence that the US Supreme
Court will quickly rule in our favor and
finally put an end to these unamerican
lawsuits campaign smoke uh spokesman for
the campaign said the court said they
had quote little difficulty concluding
that substantial evidence existed that
showed a concerted and public use of
force or threat of force by a group of
people to hinder or prevent the US
government from taking the actions
necessary to accomplish the peaceful
transfer of power in the country the
court said that because of this the
events of January 6th constituted an
Insurrection we do not reach these
conclusions lightly the court said in
its ruling we are mindful of the
magnitude and weight of these questions
now before us we are likewise mindful of
our solemn duty to apply the law without
fear or favor and without being swayed
by public reaction to the decisions that
the law mandates we reach so let me just
blue sky this thing for you for just a
moment before we get into some of the
legales and some of the reaction the
sort of big picture here thing or the
big picture thing here is that removing
Donald Trump from any state ballot
removing any candidate from any state
ballot having the courts do that by a 43
ruling that's as close as it can get is
not good for democracy it does not
matter if you hate Donald Trump it it
does not matter if you think that
January 6th was an Insurrection which I
think at this point most sane people can
object objectively say it was not these
people did not have weapons there was no
organization there was no plan to take
over the government that would have been
an Insurrection right there was a bunch
of sort of confused muddled people some
of whom yeah plan to be a bit violent
some of whom were just there to see what
was going on we know there were FBI
agents there were learning more from the
video that is now being released since
Mike Johnson took over as Speaker of the
House there's just like a whole mess of
stuff there but I almost think it's a
waste of time to even discuss the
validity or exactly what happened on
January 6 is almost a moot point at the
moment the thing that is not mot at the
moment is that we are now in the midst
of a presidential primary season leading
us to a general election and Donald
Trump whether I like it or not whether
you like it or not or whatever
apparently is the leading candidate on
the Republican side and whether he was
leading or not the idea that one Court
in one state would try to hamper him
from being on the ballot which in
essence you know if Colorado also is a
purple state right Colorado could go
either way so it is an important state
it's not just some state that he was
automatically going to lose anyway uh
it's a it's a huge huge problem this is
not good for democracy this is this is
Banana Republic level stuff and most
people most honest Arbiters and I was
somewhat pleased actually to see this
online yesterday even even from a couple
people who I've either lost some respect
for or never respected in the first
place like people are kind of getting it
the courts cannot decide this like this
is this is bad news for the future So
speaking of bad news over on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC they were covering Trump being
removed from the Colorado ballot which
by the way will now be hung up in the
Colorado Court on appeal and then the
the hope is so I guess we'll find out
about that Appeal on January 4th so now
of course we have to roll through
Christmas and the new year with this
nonsense it could end up at the Supreme
Court now at the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court happens to lean more
conservative and I think most people
regardless of a conservative court or or
a liberal Court most people don't think
this will stand up to the Supreme Court
right like they just don't think this is
the right thing for democracy and it
won't stand but either way the president
of doing this sort of thing is not good
so now to the televised mental
institution over over at MSNBC they
brought on Rachel mattow Rachel matow
who has been wrong about everything
whether it was Trump impeachment and
Russia collusion and Co all of the big
stuff if you pick a big issue Rachel mat
has been wrong about it well listen to
her uh brilliant political analysis of
what just happened I mean listen I I
think in the in the broad Strokes in
terms of our democracy there are very
few magic wands there are there are very
few sort of um you know magic spells
that you cast that um make a make a
complex and difficult problem go away
that just it just doesn't happen very
often in our political system and I
think that we shouldn't be under any
Illusions um about the the character and
the partisan inclinations among other
things of of this current Supreme Court
as it is constituted that said it is not
it is this is not a crazy thing for a
democracy to do this is um this is this
is something that was a Hallmark of
postwar Germany after World War II this
is something that happened to Jer
bolsonaro in Brazil quite recently this
is something that our own Congress did
in 1868 after our own Civil War
specifically to preclude anybody from
holding office in this country who had
engaged an Insurrection against this
country and so it's it's not unheard of
but it's it would it would be an
incredible Wild Card ah well it sounds
like she got the magic wand or the magic
potion that she wants at least
temporarily I don't think she's going to
get it longterm we shall see she has a
pretty bad track record of uh getting
things right so we'll see on that um
the idea though that the Supreme Court
is partisan you know it's so interesting
because the Supreme Court right now
generally because of the makeup of the
Court does lean more conservative but
that doesn't mean it's partisan these
people tell you what their Judicial
philosophy is right they go through the
entire process of getting nominated and
they have their hearings in front of the
Supreme Court they get nominated and
then often they go the other way right
John Roberts people thought he was going
to be the allstar for conservatives and
he's in many ways been a a little more
on the liberal side or at least a little
more in the middle so she's only saying
the Supreme Court is partisan because
she thinks that the Supreme Court is not
going to do what she wants it's
interesting she doesn't mention whether
she thinks that the Colorado Court that
did this is partisan they did what she
wanted so she's not going to reference
whether they're partisan at all uh but
anyway watch this this one's going to
blow your mind because every now and
again and I like to give credit where
credit is due every now and again on
mainstream media a sane voice is heard
now this guy's not always saying we've
played some clips of him over the years
but every now and again it breaks
through even on CNN MSNBC Etc watch this
this is Jonathan Turley he's a he's a
presidential historian if I'm not
mistaken or is he a lawyer or a
presidential historian I will find out
on the other side but take a
look well this court just handed
partisans on both sides uh the ultimate
tool to try to a shortcut elections and
it's very very dangerous I mean this
country is a powder cake
and this court is just throwing matches
at it and I think that uh it's a real
mistake but I think that they're wrong
on the law you know January 6 was many
things most of it not good in my view it
was not Insurrection it was a riot that
doesn't mean that the people responsible
for that day shouldn't be held
accountable I but to call this an
Insurrection for the purposes of
disqualification uh would create a
slippery slope for every state in the
Union
this is a time when we actually need
democracy we need to allow the the
voters to vote we need to hear their
decision and the court here just said
you're not going to get that uh in
Colorado we're not going to let you vote
for Donald Trump no and you know you
could dislike Trump you can believe he's
responsible for January 6 but this isn't
the way to do it I mean it is you know
for people that say they're trying to
protect democracy this is hands down the
most anti-democrat opinion I've seen my
lifetime you guys know I'm not above
correcting myself that was not sanity
breaking through on CNN or MSNBC my bad
that was Fox News I guess it's not that
surprising that they brought on Turley
Turley is a lawyer and a professor by
the way but of course everything he said
there was right the very people who
purport to be defending democracy from
Donald Trump are the people who are
taking the front runner out or hoping to
take the front runner out of the race
that is not protecting democracy and
even if again you thought that what
happened on January 6th was really
really bad and you thought Trump had
something to do with it if we just start
saying well the will of the people
should just be ignored right and certain
States will just decide who people can
vote for right so let's say let's say
they get away with this let's say
Colorado actually gets away with this
for some reason it doesn't get to the
Supreme Court or the Supreme Court
doesn't reverse it if it does get there
what precedent have We Now set well any
state on any given moment can be like
all right we're just not going to put
that guy on the ballot what what would
stop California the next time from
saying you know they have a highly
partisan Court they have a highly
partisan you know system from top to
bottom what would them stop them from
saying all right we're not going to put
Republicans on the ballot anymore I mean
not the Republicans ever win anything
there but you get the point like once we
do this you're just sort of removing any
validity from the system and that is a
huge huge problem Donald Trump was
campaigning in Iowa last night and he
responded to what happened in Colorado
it's no wonder crooked Joe Biden and the
far-left lunatics are desperate to stop
us by any means necessary they willing
to violate the US constitutions at
levels never seen before in order to win
this election Joe Biden is a threat to
democracy it's a
threat they're weaponizing law
enforcement for highlevel election
interference because we're beating them
so badly in the poll all right if we're
to believe the polls what Trump is
saying right there is true I mean
virtually every poll right now when they
show you the head-to-head Trump and
Biden Trump is now winning uh Brock just
made the point that any Red State today
should just announce that they're taking
Biden off the ballot like you guys want
to do this we'll do this but you see
what that is like it's it's a joke
obviously but it was a joke
right maybe uh but the point is if you
start doing this Tit for Tat thing oh
you see what they did in that state they
don't they got rid of our guy they
didn't like him why don't we see if we
can get more judges in that will act
hourly by the way the four to3 court if
I'm not mistaken uh we all appointed by
Democrat Governors um so again that goes
to the partisan part that Rachel matow
is not going to want to tell you about
now I want to show you some of the
reaction from across the political
spectrum and most of it actually was
pretty good uh we'll start with RFK Jr
who was I think he still considers
himself a kind of old school liberal but
he is no longer a Democrat now running
as an independent who is not allowed to
campaign in the early primary States uh
against Joe Biden because if he even
shows up in the states the DNC which is
way more corrupt than virtually any
other institution in the country and
we've got some pretty corrupt
institutions they said that if you
campaign in these states we will not
allow anyone to vote for you uh so the
Democrats Trump is Right are no friends
of democracy nor is Joe Biden but here's
rfk's response every American should be
troubled by the Colorado Supreme Court's
decision to remove president Trump from
the ballot he continued with about an
eight tweet thread but that gets to the
heart of it now let's get to the guy on
the Republican side of things who I
suppose has the most to gain if Trump
can't be on the ballot but he did the
right thing uh this is Ronda santis the
left invokes democracy to justify its
use of power even if it means abusing
judicial power to remove a candidate
from the ballot based on spirous legal
grounds scotus should
reverse yes uh here's VC I pledge to
withdraw from the Colorado GOP Primary
ballot until Trump is also allowed to be
on the ballot and I demand that Ron Dan
santis Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same immediately or else they are
tacitly endorsing this illegal maneuver
which will have disastrous consequences
for our country um he's making he's
making his political move that's what VC
is very good about like how do you
control media how do you get the social
media people behind you who knows if VC
was even going to make it to the
Colorado primary also demanding anything
from to santis or anyone else whatever
that's a little silly but okay the heart
of it I I'll go with uh this is from the
Colorado Republican uh party you won't
have to uh this is in response to bbec
you won't have to because we will
withdraw from the primary as a party and
convert to a pure caucus system if this
is allowed to stand uh let's jump over
to JD Vance obviously senator from Ohio
who's a big Trump guy uh talking about
how the ruling really this isn't about
Trump that that's the point this isn't
about Trump this is about a bunch of
Judges saying oh people we will not
respect your ability to vote make
decisions for yourself we will tell you
who it's okay to vote for or not kay
it's an effort to stop Donald Trump not
at The Ballot Box because right now they
don't think they can beat Donald Trump
at The Ballot Box but to use laware to
use the legal process as a political
weapon to take rights away from American
voters I I will repeat this again and
again this is not just about Donald
Trump this is about millions of American
voters who are being told by judges in
Colorado you don't get to vote for the
candidate that you would like to vote
for how is that democracy and how is
this in in any way consistent with the
hows of Republicans allegedly being a
threat to democracy and then left-wing
judges are telling Americans you don't
get to vote for the candidate that you
want to vote for it it's Preposterous K
Kaye here's another thing and just to
make a political point you've had
brilliant legal
the question I think for Republican
voters is do we let left-wing radicals
choose our nominee they are staring Us
in the face saying we dare you to select
Donald Trump as your nominee you know
one of the interesting things about this
and of course I agreee with everything
JD said there is that it seems to me
that the system actually does want Trump
right so the the top layer version of
this is like oh my God look at all the
ways the system is trying to destroy
Trump there's the case in New York
there's the case in Georgia uh there's
what's happening in Colorado and all of
that like the easy version of that at
the top layer is oh my God they're doing
horrible things to Trump and in another
way if you look a little bit deeper or
you think a little bit more if you want
to play a little bit of 4D chess doesn't
it seem like if none of these cases had
come
up this decision hadn't been made in
Colorado right that there wouldn't be as
much momentum behind Trump every time
they do one of these things it ignites
the base it gets more people to be like
boy Donald Trump is the one Outsider
fighting for us so there's like this
very strange selective pressure that's
going on with the system which on one
hand tells you that Trump is Hitler on
the other hand gets an awful lot of
clicks off of Hitler and at the same
time I think also wants to prop him up
because they think he's actually the
most beatable or he'll be so lost in
lawfare unjust lawfare that he won't be
able to run a national campaign properly
like you just have to think about the
multiple layers here don't just think
about this says oh my God they're just
going after him and it's just because
they want to stop him everybody the
pundits everybody has their own reasons
that they want people in or out or how
they're going to get attention and
everything else I want to show you one
more person on this uh because I thought
she's an interesting voice at the moment
uh tulsey gabt of course again former
Democrat now an independent though in
the last in the midterms did campaign
with a whole bunch of Republicans she
wrote Democratic leaders have C have
completely lost faith in democracy and
that to me is the heart of what's going
on here that is it it again it does not
matter I'll say this till I'm blew him
in the face it doesn't really matter
what you think happened on January 6th
Donald Trump is running for president
you may like him you may hate him
everything else if the courts are
allowed to do this and basically just
take him off the
chessboard what comes after
this you can think of a couple things
that come after this right we just will
not have elections anymore courts will
decide who will be president we'll
suspend elections Blah Blah Blah by the
way Trump is has some blood on his hands
related to this like he's not debating
right now eventually if you don't have
debates long enough then why have
elections right like everyone's kind of
messy here I want to show you a video uh
since I just mentioned Tulsi just a
couple days ago this was at a turning
point event and Tulsi went there uh and
this is before obviously the Colorado
Hearing and she was talking about how
it's up to us to defend our freedoms
it's up to us to defend our country and
defend our freedom who we vote for
matters being involved in this process
matters yes there are flaws and it needs
to be fixed but we can't fix anything
unless our voices are heard we have to
elect leaders who are committed to
supporting and defending the
Constitution putting the interests and
the needs of the American people above
all
else we will defend our freedoms by
exercising them
we can uphold and protect the truth by
speaking the truth to those who reject
it the line that I particularly like
there was we can't fix anything unless
our voices are heard so doesn't this
hearing uh sorry doesn't this Colorado
ruling come across like they're trying
to take our voices away there are plenty
of people in Colorado that want to vote
in a Republican primary that is fair
that will put everyone that is running
on that ballot and allow them to run and
then subsequently whoever wins the
Republican primary will then have their
name on the general election ballot and
if a court by a 4 to3 ruling all by
Democrat Governors all appointed by
Democrat Governors if they say to the
people of Colorado well your voice
doesn't matter that much we've decided
that's an Insurrection they didn't have
any plans to take over the government
they weren't taking over the military
they didn't have any weapons we did have
FBI agents out there it's we were moving
barricades letting people enter opening
doors for people joking around with
people taking selfies with people but we
the court have decided that what we
think about that election about that
future election is far more important
than what you think about it that is
Banana Republic level stuff and again I
have no problem defending Trump I have
no problem defending the truth and what
is right and everything else and I was
glad to see again I was glad to see the
santis I was glad to see RFK I'm glad to
see Tulsi Etc standing up for what's
right Chris Christie by the way put out
a good statement
he said he's not going to get off the
ballot but he will fight for what's
right and and Christie hates Trump so
every now and again some people do the
right thing for the right thing sake and
I think that that's important anyway
this story obviously ain't going
anywhere so stay tuned on all that but
it sounds like the appeal will be
January 4th and then I suppose if the
appeal doesn't go Trump's way then they
will try to get it up to the Supreme
Court I don't know how how long that
lays out but it's like we could just
have more and more every day it's like
could this get any crazier and then
they just take us further into crazy
town so may God have mercy on us all all
right we're going to get to a Ruben
report locals Community Q&A in just a
sec let me talk to you guys about the
satellite phone store are you guys in
the need for the SAT for a satellite
phone well sat1 123.com has made it easy
for anyone to get one satellite phones
are a secure way to communicate with no
tracking and no one can listen to your
calls or read your texts the ammer stat
ISAT satellite phone is free on a
15-month agreement limited time only an
extra free battery is also included
$95.95 per month no cost for the phone
100 minutes or texts are also included
family plan multi-f free phones are also
available an extra free battery for each
phone is also included these phones will
work from anywhere on Earth cell phones
work on only 7% of the earth if you can
see the sky you will be able to make a
call if the cellular networks go down
you'll still be able to stay in
communication with loved ones but
satellite phones will always work all
satellite phones and Communications are
encrypted Ensure privacy by using
proprietary satellite networks entrusted
by the US government for decades the US
Senate recently issued a satellite phone
for private calls and security satellite
phones can't be tracked big Tech can't
access your data this year in the US we
experienced the Maui cell phone service
going down 90% of the island 60,000
people stuck in the desert where only
people with satellite phones were able
to communicate hurricanes took sell
service down be prepared be prepared go
to sat23 and get your family ready
Christmas Time Is Here gift your family
Safety and Security in connections and
now back to me all right let's dive into
a community Q&A let's see if we can get
one or two extra ones on the Fly Brock
is waiting if you are at Ruben report.
locals.com right now you can enter uh
comments questions etc etc Julia says
Dave do you think that people are being
paid to attend pramas rallies I don't
know for sure however we do know that
Nos and nonprofits they are out there
putting out all of those signs putting
out the kefas putting out the messaging
they send people there that lead the
chance they tell them which ways to go
down on the street they have people
tracking where police are like this is a
major people need to understand this is
not organic this is exactly it's exactly
what BLM did it is the same exact thing
in many cases run by the same exact
people the same exact NOS there is no
doubt they are coordinating with
interntional
organizations um which is why I think
that what the next layer of protection
against this is because you know you
can't just let these people just okay
they could just take over Penn Station
just take over Penn Station stop
families from getting out of the city uh
because you're you're Pro River to the
Sea genocide no it's not how a
functional Society can work you can't
take over Penn Station you can't take
over Grand Central Station you can't
take over the Manhattan Bridge you can't
take over the 405 in La except you can
right the thing is they can and they
know they can and the next level that
responsible governments are going to
have to do and we've already passed some
laws on this on in Florida I don't know
that it's going to happen in the blue
States is you're going to have to look
into material support for these
organizations right so like students for
justice in Palestine has been banned
from a couple colleges here in Florida
because they were able to look at it the
Florida government led by Ronda sanos
was able to look at these organizations
and they weren't stopping them for from
speaking up using exercising their Free
Speech but they figure out what material
is are they coordinating who are they
getting money from where do these NGS
get their money from that then pay for
things for these students to be out on
the streets with etc etc so I don't know
about direct payments I would guess
there is some level of that you have to
think a couple layers uh deeper and and
I really mean this about just something
about the the you guys saw the videos we
played them on the show yesterday I
think telling about Penn Station and
Grand Central being taken over again and
that nobody does anything societies
can't last like this for very long if
you have a bunch of masked guys that
look like Cobra soldiers from gi. Joe
screaming that they're going to kill
people and they want genocide and all of
the rest of it and even if they weren't
even saying anything bad if they just
take over places of
Transit and then people can't get in and
out of the city freely like you can't
really have Commerce there this is the
holiday season they're going to the
Christmas tree at Rockefeller
Rockefeller Center at some point it
breaks down everything that brings us
together and the scary part is maybe
we've already CRA uh crossed that
uncanny valley in several of these
cities we probably have I I think I
referenced on Fox yesterday it's like
it's like who's coming to save New York
City at this point
110,000 uh new illegal immigrants are
now in that City the the city system is
stretch thin we know that law
enforcement is fleeing the NYPD had to
lower the the qualifications to become
an officer they don't have the backing
of the mayor who so how does any of this
turn around what does That Rock Bottom
thing look like until it gets reversed I
I don't know what the answer to that is
uh Veronica says have really enjoyed the
people of the internet show uh what is
something that you have learned or
surprised you about the community from
the callers that you've had so I've
really enjoyed it too you know we
started it two months ago and Isabelle
Brown is my co-host we do it at one
o'clock uh Monday through Thursday and I
really enjoy it we talk to you guys uh
we play some viral clips of the day uh
what is something I've learned well
first off we have an awful lot of fans
in North Carolina there is a very
disproportion amount of people calling
in from North Carolina I did a show it
was sold out show in Raleigh for the for
the don't burn this country uh book tour
but I had no idea that I had so many
fans in in North Carolina so I my
father-in-law lives there I got to get
to North Carolina to see what's going on
um well you know what's been really nice
is that the ages um I you know I don't
care about gender or sexuality or skin
color or anything but are the ages of
the people are kind of all over the
place we have we have people that are
calling us that are 18 19 years old we
have people that are calling us probably
up into their 70s 80s it's kind of
everywhere and I just love I mean my my
idea of the show was that when I'm in
the locals community and when we do
these Community q&as or I'm doing a chat
with you guys or even if I'm just like
flipping through the feed I just see
things that are like a little more
interesting than a lot of what I'm
seeing from the pundit class like you
guys have as many legit thoughts as I do
or anyone else that does something like
this and I can learn a little bit along
the way you have interesting ways of
talking about things I also think that
people who who like politics but aren't
like in it in it there's a there's a
fresh view that you can offer to that
and I think it's helped me offer a fresh
perspective when I'm doing this show
actually Douglas Murray fan that is a
fine handle says hey Dave thank you for
your great work I'm wondering what you
think about the rising terrorist threats
in countries like the US and Canada are
we doomed to become like Europe what
will be the outcome of these problems is
there any way uh to mitigate it at this
point I'm I'm very worried and I think
everybody should be very worried uh with
when you look at these videos of what's
going on on our borders right now we
have no idea who has come in over the
last couple years we have no idea who's
coming in the last couple weeks we
showed you the videos yesterday of these
people getting through the Border in
Arizona and then they immediately are
put on planes and sent to New York
they're put on planes they're sent to
Chicago we don't know where these people
are coming from we don't know what their
intentions are they don't necessarily
have jobs lined up or families or
anything else not that even having those
things would make it legit to get into
country illegally in the first place um
but there is a huge uh War Brewing right
now in the Middle East it's happening
and and a bigger War could be Brewing uh
these people have told us what their
intentions are with the West right
Israel's the little Satan you know who
the big Satan is it's America uh when
you see the the protests that are
happening in Europe mean when I was in
London for the Jordan conference one
night I was going from the hotel to the
venue and I did have armed security with
me on that trip and and we drove the
road we drove by like there was a mass
pramas rally there and you know we
stopped at a red light for a second and
I had like this weird thought of like
you know if these people knew I was in
the car or if I got out of the car for a
second like what would they do to me um
are we going to lead to a place where
there will be suicide bombings and
stabbings and bus bombings and all of
those things like they've been doing to
Israel for years in all of our countries
like why wouldn't they do it if you
don't if if their belief is that the
Jews don't have anything to do with the
ancient land of Israel what do you what
do you think they think your um your uh
responsib not your responsibility what
do they think your um ownership over the
land of America is probably let's say 10
you as at best so I am worried about
that that's depressing better get what
this next one better do something here
for me James says what are you looking
forward to professionally and personally
in 2024 okay that was better uh well
personally it's just like the kids are
growing now and they're starting to talk
more and like just it's just more fun
now to like be able to throw them around
and we got some outdoor stuff that they
can climb on and all that kind of stuff
so like just watching where they go I
think that's like the main personal
thing for me at the moment and I think
in the first uh I would say in the last
couple months I've enjoyed like being a
father more when I get up in the morning
and they're just like exploding with
energy and joy and happiness and they're
just so happy to see you and as I've
said before like they're just worlds are
so open and you're just like whoa you
can fill them up with the right things
and then maybe put them out in the world
and maybe they could do some cool things
and you have to look back on that in you
know 30 years and go all right I guess
maybe I did an okay job if if you
hopefully did um and and to be able to
inoculate them from some of the lunacy
that we see all over the place so
personally most of the stuff I would say
um is is about the kids uh
professionally I mean this this was as
it fortunately has been for a couple
years now uh this has been the best year
of the show it was by far the biggest
Year my man Chris just sent us all of
our analytics for the year and basically
every month we broke every single record
across platforms on social media
crushing it like everything's working
the live streams the whole thing so I
think the content that we're doing um
has been really nice uh I mentioned this
I think on a postgame show but I'll just
say it real quick on this show I don't
mean this to brag but it was just a
really nice moment I got a call from Bob
cus a week ago broadcast Legend BR Bob
casus sports legend Bob kasas I've never
communicated with Bob but I got a call
from Bob and he just wanted telling me
he thought I was a great
broadcaster pretty freaking cool like um
you know I got to do Bill Mah which I
had wanted real time which I had wanted
to do for quite literally 20 or 25 years
even before real time existed when it
was Politically Incorrect and I was in
high school um so I think this is just
the beginning I also think that um you
know I've seen an awful lot of people in
my space kind of lose their mind because
of the election I've seen a you know a
sort of grifter class just emerge and I
will just continue to try to tell you
the truth and tell you what I think and
and not be infected by a lot of the
nonsense and as it relates to what we
talked about at the top of the show this
Colorado thing like a lot of nonsense is
coming down the pike right we still have
10 months to this election to the
presidential election but we still got
to get through these primaries we still
got to get through the Trump court cases
we got to get through whatever else
they're going to throw us whether it's
an escalation in the Middle East or it's
an escalation in Ukraine or Joe Biden's
working on three more covid vacin or the
Alien Invasion or they shut down the
interet or all the crazy stuff and uh I
guess we'll do it together so there you
go cam says I may have asked this before
but who but do you think the wef the wh
Bill Gates and the rest of the clowns
who want to control the world have
thought about how they'd control the
Middle East and especially the terrorist
groups um you know how do you control
the terrorist groups is a really
interesting one so let's say you got
control good idea for a dystopia movie
right let's say you got control over
most of the Western Government like it
does feel like they have control of
Canada now right like Justin Trudeau is
one of their Stooges it feels like we're
pretty damn close to them fully having
control of the United States it seems
like they they certainly have control of
Brussels and some of the Western
European
countries that's one thing to control
societies where the people basically
behave under the rule of law but how do
you control areas Middle East places
where the governments don't have that
much control where violence is much more
rampant where you have sectarian
violence where terrorism is just part of
the day-to-day life I don't know how you
control that and I don't know where
these people how these people think that
they will be fully inoculated from it
you know these people at least as far as
I know whether it's Bill Gates or John
krey or CL Schwab or any these people
these people still have to live on earth
I don't know exact you know I know Bill
Gates has like a you know he's got many
houses and he's the largest Farmland
owner in the United States but at some
point you can't have all of the
societies collapsing everywhere because
it will reach your doorstep unless
they're all living Underground or which
I don't think they want to do or leaving
the planet all together I mean God only
knows what these people are planning so
I don't know the exact answer to that CL
jansz says good morning Dave how are you
and David bringing in the New Year we
usually leave the holidays for amateurs
to celebrate and we stay home well this
is going to be the first year in about
seven years that I think we're just
going to do a low-key thing uh we have
friends in Miami even before we lived in
Miami who always for for a long many
many years have had an awesome blowout
crazy Mo uh uh New Year's party but it
doesn't look like it's happening this
this year so I think we're just going to
stay at home and watch a movie and I
don't know maybe we'll have some friends
over and I'll make some stakes and we'll
pop some champagne and just kind of ease
into it I think that'll I think that'll
be okay uh John says what is your
opinion on Tucker Carlson's comments at
America Fest concerning desantis's
online
supporters
uh if you didn't see it Tucker uh was on
Tim pool's show they did a live version
of it at this Turning Point event and
Tucker was on with Tim P Charlie Kirk I
think there might have been one other
guy there and they were kind of going
off on Des San's online supporters about
how mean they are and whatever it's like
come on guys I get it I get it you're
all in team Trump right now um but if
you think that the online DeSantis
supporters are somehow meaner or they
they have Behavior that's worse than the
Trump supporters like that's crazy like
Roger Stone called Casey DeSantis a
and said she faked her cancer right I've
just said the seword back toback days we
need a we need to the
year um like like I have seen such
insane Behavior you know these Laura
lumer crazy people who said horrible
things about me people trying to dox
people but I I don't think it I don't
think it behooves anyone to get into who
who's worse or whatever you know Trump
with the sanctimonious calling people
names all of those things I think what
it
really what it really shows is that
people just go off in their directions
Trump uh sorry Tucker uh Tim P these
guys like they're on team Trump now so
they want to do everything to destroy
the santis right like that that is just
how it is I have tried to play this as
honestly as possible I think I I think I
did that rather effectively at the top
of the show today right to defend Trump
without reservation when when it is
worth defending uh but you know there's
selective pressures when it comes to you
you want clicks you want likes and
everything else but I'd be happy to
discuss this with any of those guys for
real and I think I'm interviewing Tucker
or we're going to do a back and forth
interview or something in January so
stay tuned uh presky says I would just
like to say uh to the Ruben report team
and Dave happy Hanukkah and I hope you
and your families have a wonderful
Christmas and great new year also thank
you for what you do my question is if
Congress and the Senate can fire Santos
for the illegal things he's done
shouldn't people like ilhan Omar Rashid
AOC and the rest of the Hamas caucus be
fired as well for supporting a terrorist
group like Hamas it is a great question
and it and it goes to how we can all sit
here all day long and say the Democrats
are idiots and the wers are morons and
these purple haired asexual losers are
blah blah blah blah blah but in many
ways they congregate and coordinate way
better than we do way better than we do
I don't even know exactly what Santos
did or did not do I'm not even totally
sure but I have no doubt that Rashida TB
has done far worse and yes she was
censured by Congress but she is still in
Congress and there is no doubt that she
is 100% a supporter of a foreign
terrorist organization like there is
just absolutely no doubt of that and
you're right ilhan Omar is and AOC is
but TB is TB is like the one when it
comes to this thing she's the general
there um but Republicans are weak right
I mean what do I always say like you
know you don't have to be a republican
but you can't be a Democrat and the
reason I say that is because the
Republicans kind of suck too especially
at the national level we have pockets
where they're really good Florida has a
really good Republican
machine the national Republicans just
ain't that great Larry says do you have
unspoken limits on what issues you were
willing to explore or discuss on your
shows or who you're willing to interview
that that's a good question I mean
unspoken I mean I suppose there are some
limits like I don't really have a desire
to sit down with a white supremacist or
something like that and I wouldn't have
a desire to sit down with a uh you know
a jihadist or something certainly not in
my house not going to invite those
people over I think that it look I'm not
for jailing people for having odious
beliefs obviously and they can they can
share those beliefs with their friends
and family and and everything else you
can't do it on other people's property
but I don't have to give air to
everything I think one of the things
that's been sort of interesting for me
over the years is I was put on the map
as one of the Free Speech guys because I
was coming from the left and I was
willing to talk to people on the right
and then by doing that I got endless
hate from the left like how could you
talk to these mean people like Ben
Shapiro and Dennis Prager and Jordan
Peterson who all turned out to be you
know let's say like certainly within the
Overton window of normal conservative
beliefs that most people have but I was
hated by the left for that and that's
one of the things that the left did it
kept shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking that over in window of what
we're allowed to talk about and who
we're allowed to talk to so I got pushed
out just for talking to people and then
ironically what we found out about the
left over the last couple years is as
they Shrunk The ideas you're allowed to
talk about it it created a very toxic
set of ideas that you could talk about
right because you everything had to be
then seen within that woke prism and now
you have literally Harvard students
calling for genocide so um I suppose I
don't know if it's spoken or unspoken I
mean I I can tell you this when we set
up the show every day all day long I'm
I'm sending I see things on Twitter or
wherever they are I send them to Phoenix
throughout the day we put the show
together in the morning sometimes we
change something or we'll change an
order it's very rare I'm trying to think
one time maybe we scrapped the entire
show and redid it over all together did
we even do that once maybe once like 75%
but we we have a pretty good sense of of
kind of what we want to do and whatever
but if you guys see a blind spot on that
I'd be happy to hear it Lori says people
believe that the First Amendment
reference to religion is simply about
separation of church and state I believe
the actual intent was pre to prevent the
government from establishing a state
religion does it appear to you the state
is trying to force an a religious world
view Upon Us ah this is a this is a good
question that I I would like to do a
little bit more of this in in the next
year um are they trying to put an A-
religious view on us well look if you
have a perfectly secular Society it's
very hard to have institutions that last
right and I think that's why we're
seeing most of our purely secular
institutions fail our our schools and
our IV leagues and all of these things
they're they're just collapsing our our
places of science The Who and the CDC
like this purely secular worldview I
think perhaps in places like uh
Cambridge or Oxford across the pond
where there was like you know very
powerful Divinity schools that were as
respected as all of the say Natural
Sciences and things of that nature there
was like an understanding like you have
to have a little of that and a little of
this to make it work right you have to
have a little of like you could you know
you want to call it like the imagination
with pure science but or that Leap of
Faith with what we can empirically prove
and I think societies are trying to now
figure that out um I am not here to
force anyone to believe anything
religiously or anything else and and and
absolutely the founders did not want
that but at some point if you have a
completely
moralist Society then no one will follow
the laws you know it's it's sort of why
what the Democrats have done is so
dangerous right they tried to destroy
all of our previous beliefs they tried
to destroy our founding documents and a
true assessment of history and then and
they also tell you that you know the
whole founding was bad and all of those
things and then they say and also by the
way we're not going to make it so that
you actually have to abide by laws and
things like that and then you a bunch of
purple-haired crazy people who don't
know that their genitals have anything
to do with their gender stealing Lulu
Lemon pants and punching police officers
in the face and calling for genocide and
you wonder how you got here so yes we
should do more on that in the New Year
David says uh who are some of your
favorite journalists out there well
there aren't many good journalists I
would say Megan Kelly in terms of like
if you were to look at the type of
people like me that try to present
things in an honest way that I know
personally and privately I I know some
people that that I'm not going to throw
under the bus at the moment but that
personally and privately are very very
different like the guy that's huge in
Trump World who was at my house in March
telling me that he loved the santis and
Trump was too old and everything else
who's out there you know who you are guy
or gal um but there are some people that
are the same way both sides and I would
say Megan is exactly the same way both
sides and I think she really tries to
call balls and Strikes but in terms of
journalists like out there doing
journalism I think Bill maluan is doing
a great job you know we covered some of
his stuff yesterday he's usually on the
border for Fox uh what's his name Peter
Ducey over at also at Fox but he's the
guy at the White House Press briefings I
think he's doing a really nice job I'd
say Andy no my friend who's now over in
London because he was in Portland for
years and it became very unsafe for him
to live there and he's really covering a
lot of what's going on on the kind of
jihadist front and the and the antifa
front in London um who else give me one
or two journalists that we like James
O'Keefe obviously formerly of veritas I
think he's doing his own thing now with
some of that uh undercover stff oh Greg
price who we we do play a lot of clips
from Greg price he does a nice job you
just got to kind of find people and and
you know you test them over time boy did
you really blow that story did you
really lead me down the wrong path on
that one and if you have a pretty good
track record then I think they're worthy
of of sticking with Einstein says have
you ever visited Maine our state is
beautiful but derailed I don't think
I've ever been in Maine but it's funny
that you say it's beautiful and derailed
because I'm fairly certain I have a
cousin there and I'm think she's a
socialist I unfollowed her on Instagram
I couldn't take it anymore so I'm not
kidding I should find out what's going
on there uh big says what was your
favorite Hanukkah president present ever
as a kid I so I did see this question in
advance so I could get you the picture I
have referenced this before so you guys
know I was a big transformers guy back
in the day so that is the original like
1984 1985 Megatron and of course he was
the leader of the Decepticons and as you
can see he transformed into a gun and
the reason this was my favorite gift was
because for like two years I really
wanted Megatron and I had Soundwave
who's who's right over here Conor can we
jump to that there's Soundwave right
there uh and I had you know star scream
and the rest of them but my parents
would not let me get Megatron because he
transformed into a gun and they thought
our guns what are we going to do he's
going to grow up and start shooting
people because that's how it works and
whatever and then one of my friends Josh
got
Megatron and F some and he was pretty
good he was pretty bright kid he was
actually very bright they used to wheel
in a cart from an more advanced I think
when we were in like third grade they
would wheel in a cart of fourth grade
stuff for him so he was bright and my
parents were like oh Josh got Megatron
we will allow David to get Megatron and
then let's put Megatron back up I got
Megatron ended up robbing a bank uh when
I was SE uh sixth grade robbed the bank
made away with $45,000 it was pretty
good Terry says what were some of the
highlights for you this year in 23 uh
well in terms of the show I mean
especially in light of what's happened
over the last couple months that that uh
week or 10 days that we spent in Israel
was was so magical um it it was so
peaceful and wonderful and seeing a
place that that had so much ancient
stuff and so much new stuff and and
especially Jerusalem where we spent more
time than I had ever spent in Jerusalem
our first I think four or five days were
there and watching them excavate and and
literally uncover the past and show you
the to go to the city of David where uh
it's right outside the old city of
Jerusalem and know that you're walking
down the same paths that Jesus walked
you know when he was going to the to the
temple in the ancient days and then to
be right outside of that and see these
absolutely gorgeous everything in
Jerusalem has to be built with Jerusalem
Stone and see these beautiful buildings
going up and you just see both ways you
see you see the past and the future at
the exact same time it was just it was
just wonderful and and especially in
light of the situation now um you know I
don't know that I would that I certainly
will go back I'm actually trying to
figure out if I can even get back there
in January for a little bit um but will
I ever feel that that it feels very
innocent it's kind of funny to think
that I suppose that you would go to the
Middle East and think it felt kind of
innocent but but in light of recent
events it kind of feels that that was
probably the main highlight obviously
the mar thing was a big highlight um
building this studio which I think is
really the most beautiful studio in the
biz like look at this place like I'm so
proud We we did this all by we brought
in some contractors obviously but we
designed it ourselves the art the color
scheme the whole thing um filling out
the team our new guy Joey who's right
over there uh I feel like we have the
right team in this studio will be
expanding a little bit into the next
year like we just kind of did that stuff
right so it was it was a really good
year around here and I I uh I truly
thank you guys for that uh on that note
uh are we doing a postgame show today we
we are doing a postgame show today I
don't even know why I asked we do a
postgame show every day Ruben report.
locals.com if you want to get in a
couple extra questions uh the merch
store is up at as I mentioned Dave ruin.
store and although we did not cold open
you today we will cold close you with a
little Klan
Cala goodbye been saying you can't do it
by executive order any more than Trump
can do things when he says he can do it
by executive order does the vice
president have a point there some things
you can many things you can let's let
the senator answer well I mean I would
just say Hey Joe instead of saying no we
can't let's say yes we can
let's be
constitutional we got a
[Music]
con